also als erstes muss dieses unsinnige
zweig im einzelhandel und gastronomie
weg es ist ja völlig absurd dass es
situationen in deutschland sind wohl
jemand der nicht geimpftes ich übrigens
sagt lieber nicht geimpfte als
ungeimpfte weil für mein empfinden
steckt in dem der vorsilbe uhr eine
wertung drin unheil unrat in wahrheit
alles was mit uns anfängt ist irgendwie
negativ ich finde aber nicht geimpfte
menschen gar nicht so negativ die haben
halt für sich eine entscheidung
getroffen also es kann ja nicht sein
dass in der gastronomie ein nicht
geimpfter mit einem negativ test als
kellner arbeiten kann aber nach
dienstschluss kann im gleichen lokal
nicht essen gehen das ist jetzt also
gemeint das kriegt man nicht erklärt
oder auch bizarre dinge im flugzeug
steigt man neuerdings reihe für reihe
aus ja wer jetzt im urlaub war das
vielleicht miterlebt reihe für reihe und
dann steht unten der bussteig an alle
ein bus zurück das gibt es ja gar nicht
das bedeutet all diese absurden absurden
regeln müssen weg und in einem zweiten
schritt müssen auch die ganzen masken
regeln die hier noch mit einer mehrheit
für sehen sind aus sorge das kann ich
verstehen diskutiert werden und weg und
dann würde ich es halt jedem selber
überlassen ob er eine maske trägt um
sich zu schützen oder ob er sie nicht